hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to inscription i'm
gonna do something that's a little silly
i'm gonna put all my cards
in my deck
literally all of them
why
because i figure it's better than trying
to plan i don't know what the hell i'm
doing so i might as well just slap them
all in here and i know this is a
terrible idea but i have a funny feeling
if i get the right rng it'll work out
perfectly for me because
honestly i don't know what i'm doing and
for having a mage starter deck i don't
oh that's right i'm about to go into the
magic zone
so now i'll be able to get some more
cards then i can slap them in my deck
too
perfect hi
hello
the note reads greetings if you're
reading this it must be because you wish
to challenge me magnificus to a card
battle but in order to earn the
privilege you must first defeat my three
graduate students as for their
whereabouts that is for you to discover
sincerely magnificus
all right cool thanks
oh
nah
inside the chest is covered in a sticky
green goo but you find a card pack
finally magical cards i've been
literally yearning for these if you have
a blue gem sacrifice master bleeding to
draw three cards whoa gem fiend if
gemfin owner controls no max cards jim
fiend perishes well that seems fine
that's just a better version of the
normal thing that i have except blue
which is totally fine orange mage mox
cards on the underside of the board game
one power oh okay
handy
okay whatever if i actually had some
thought to this a strange monocle you
put it on
oh
uh
interesting oh
oh
okay
so skull wing skull is that what that's
about skull
skull wing
skull oh there we go oh
[Music]
hi i didn't want to be here just yet ah
the pain is unbearable oh it's you
do you see magnificus turned me into
bruh gu for my final exam i just need to
defeat one more challenger then i will
earn my rightful place my rightful place
in the deck of the master has one of his
prized cards arc nothing will stop me
i mean i got the worst deck imaginable
so honestly i don't think you're gonna
do too bad
[Music]
um well uh i can't do nothing and you're
about to get a
boost um let's try that again
i'm starting to realize this was a
terrible idea
ow
oh we
no that's unhelpful all right maybe this
was a bad idea
maybe putting literally every card in my
deck was a bad idea alright you did it
yes it was all worth it please report my
victory to the master quickly if
possible
okay
cool sorry about all this i'll report
right to the master don't you worry
i can't go that way
hmm
interesting oh hi bud how you doing pal
let's see oh
collected cards oh it shows me what
cards i have
well that's great if only there was a
way to get more is there any extra cards
lying around here somewhere
anybody got any cards hey buddy
you wish to trade bleen's mocks can't be
sacrificed while bleen's moxes on the
border provides blue gem to its owner
and a triangle gem that's nice whoever
this bleen guy is great i love stim mage
i want stim mage
[Music]
i love stim mage ruby golem when ruby
golden perishes a ruby mox is created in
his place
interesting but uh i'm just gonna go
ahead and get some magic packs because
it's the one i'm lacking
oh hell yeah gem fiend or lose mocks
sweet i like this
give me that
oh yeah garage is max this is great
okay let me redo my terrible stupid deck
which was a dumb idea and i i lixia just
hide everything i ever did about that
because it's not worth even mentioning
thank you thank you
all right uh
these dudes definitely because they're
just useful as father my stim mage is
absolutely my weird combo mage blue
sporange although if i don't do that
it's nice
damn it i gotta think about
why do i gotta think about this i don't
like thinking thinking's not what i'm
about skeletons are good just to have
always good i like the spore
man
uh this guy was good
definitely that guy this guy was free
which is nice
i like free cards cards that don't cost
anything are very nice but i do need
some like hard hitters
some things that hit hard it was nice to
have the mantis there mantis are good
and then these spore mice
sure and this guy all right let's try
this let's see if i finally understood
this game what are you doing i passed my
final exam we're done please please not
again ah well
sorry pal um well that's unfortunate
let's roll again
marginally better
okay let's try this
try that
it just started oh i should have
destroyed that first
ah that makes more well this is
unhelpful i guess i'll
no i'm gonna hold off on that because i
got to destroy it anyway to get through
there but i'm gonna die
all right
oh my god
oh
why
i didn't even think i i approached this
wrong anyway so it doesn't matter i
think i'm gonna just die here i
approached it completely wrong this was
not what i was supposed to do yes i pass
again please report my victory to
magnificus please have mercy i can't go
to magnificus until you're dead so it's
um
it's unfortunate but
tis the way of things
all right so what i'm gonna do get this
out get this guy out put you there then
you can kill that and then they're
powerless afterwards okay this is great
wham wham wham
cool
they're gonna do their thing
that's fine
all right
dope
and you're gonna do your thing
and then they're suddenly powerless
even though there's another one coming
up it doesn't matter they're suddenly
powerless so just hit again
uh-huh excellent now
i'm going to hold off because i want a
lot of
i want to get as much overkill as
possible and this will do two points of
damage
excellent
cool we'll do one more point of damage
actually i'm gonna put this dude here
you can start digging up some bones okay
so that'll do one point of damage and i
want to keep them at that one point of
damage
i got two bones actually
okay actually i don't think these guys
can do anything else so i wonder all
right i'm gonna i'm gonna get rid of
this guy
okay sweet they can do nothing
they can do literally nothing i love
this
okay this is great and then
i can clear out this dude
with that
and i get bones and then bones
this is fine
this is totally fine is there going to
be any problem if i just let the fight
go forever if i really want to get these
foils because i want to hit him
really hard to clear that guy
this is kind of silly but it's letting
me do it so whatever
oh man
oh wow
okay
twice as much i love it
i'm gonna just power up these bone
daddies right here
to unbelievable amounts of damage
[Laughter]
i love it
i really truly love this
or that one but i guess it doesn't
matter i love this i'm gonna break the
game with the amount of cards i'm gonna
pull out
and then i got that guy
that's also a possibility but i can't i
can't boost him up too much or else he's
just gonna do the damage anyway i'm just
gonna go until it tells me to stop
starvation session okay all right
it's time so what i'm gonna do is this
guy here
plop you right
there
load you to the tits with bones oh
my god
oh
[Laughter]
oh my god
okay and then you think i'm done nope uh
bye do i get a bone for that thank you
that's exactly what i was hoping for
because why not for good measure another
four damage right here
because i s oh whoops mox card ah
damn it did i pull another did i have
another one i don't think i had another
one of those damn it yes mantis god
that'll do two damage
kill you there put you there at another
point there we're good to go hit him
buddy
wham
[Laughter]
i should have been doing that from the
get-go
i love it no please please just tell
master i've passed he won't know the
difference here take this back
thanks
i hit him really good i hit him really
really good
that is really good
turns out the bone stuff really does
allow you to hit how hard here i can
open the door for you
all right thanks i'll tell them you won
definitely because you did and i whoa
see
[Music]
what
what the hell
is that i can't do anything about it
are there other bugs in the other places
too
[Music]
weird
that's bizarre
okay
strange
[Music]
all right you find a card pack among a
heap of other things that i didn't get
to read
all right more moxie good good good good
good good good that's great that's great
okay what's with this dude the dummy
stares lifelessly back at you
why did everything get quiet
then suddenly it brings into motion
oh hi hello
all right um if a creature would attack
force mage it does not i mean you got a
point there practice mage
don't know what this is all about
i'll do what i can though
oh
skull okay this is telling me something
skull got it okay skull
can't do anything
so i need to wait and let it do its
thing
interesting and i gotta figure out a way
to kill force mage to get the other
things
i see i see i see well
start the process again i guess
let's get some bones going
okay let me see if mantis god can attack
it indirectly so put you there
oh where's my here he is
mantis god i think let's try that
oh no it doesn't attack at all weird so
how would you kill that thing all right
well let me get rid of this guy
and let me put up my
this dude and beef them out
again i don't think this is going to
give me any foils but
hey it's worth a shot right it's worth a
all right
goodbye
oh i do
because i bet this is repeatable because
i don't exactly know what this puzzle is
the dummy hinges creak back into
position and it returns to its lifeless
state
oh you can do it again and again
you can really do it again and again
okay
got the foils so i need to look up my
deck and see if there's a way that i
could do a bomb or something to destroy
it because i don't know of any other way
unless there's another secret around
here that does allow me to do that
that just goes down
well that's unhelpful okay so there's
got to be something there was a book of
uh cards that i had collected over here
and maybe i could consult it for
something that could do it but i think a
bomb might work
although i don't want to destroy you
know because
i like it it's a lot of foil so you know
it's kind of helpful
it's kind of really helpful bomb bot
creature opposing it as well as adjacent
friendly creatures are dealt 10 damage
yeah so it tactically i think that might
work but do i want to get rid of it yet
because it seems like a good farming
thing and i have a funny feeling it
might get rid of it and i don't know
about getting rid of it getting rid of
it seems like a mistake
i don't know
i want to farm up more so
hold on to your horses
[Music]
that's a lot of damage
okay so let's see
now let's play a little more seriously
let's get ready to actually progress
instead of just like don't
around let me see if the bomb bot can
make a difference here i mean i'll do
the same thing i was doing before but
whatever uh yeah if this doesn't work
i'm gonna have to look into something
else cause i don't really know what oh
bomb bot that's convenient
uh let's see what happens
oh it needs to die or maybe i could just
sacrifice it would that work
it worked it worked interesting so if i
kill this one
wham
all right
well that's nice so skull
wing
skull wing
is that it is that all i need i might as
well get some
i should probably try to destroy those
first
there's sporey digmen
and there's the other sporey digman
let's bash these things out of existence
just in case there's something else here
i'm gonna try to kill this these things
here
so
skull wing i remember that that's fine
uh-huh ah skull wing push
right
okay
interesting skull wing push got it so
what i'm gonna do is try to kill us in
in case there's something else skull
wing push
let's do this
and just kill it up skull wing push
which i think was the same as the other
one wasn't it skull wing push
yes
and then because why the hell not
um
okay skull wing push got it now i'm not
exactly ready to fight something but i
don't think it'll do it until i'm ready
wasn't this the same as the other one
knows skull wing skull skull wing push
skull wing push
i thought it was a skull wing push maybe
it's a different order
push wing skull
okay
skull push wing
oh there we go skull push wing
oh god
oh my god
just imagine you were an ice cube slowly
melting on a hot pan
oh i was only talking to myself the pain
of being ahead impaled on a spear is
well it is worth it of course magnificus
will award me the highest honor i will
be the centerpiece of his deck
oh my god okay it does fight right away
because i talked to her oh this is not
the deck that i was hoping for
um i'm a little ill prepared for this
yard
all right well
uh excuse me i'm probably gonna lose
this because uh this is not
the deck i was looking for
um
so i'm just gonna kill this thing
hold on
wham
and then that's gonna die
and then those are there that's fine
i mean i'm gonna die so it doesn't
really matter yeah i'll just forfeit
this one it's fine i knew i was gonna
die because
i even said to myself hey don't fight
right away magnificent was watching
right surely i am only to wait a bit
longer back to my mantras
alright man
ma'am
sir i'm sorry for your suffering
i have to go because
i now need to go get some sweet cards
i get to do some back openings
oh can't wait
all right ah bone
i love the bones the bone ones are the
bomb let's go buy some bones
because you want to open some card packs
you guys want to open some card bags
i know you do hell yeah
oh interesting not too good
uh-huh oh yes
all right all right getting a lot of
bone heaps which is nice
all right more necromancers that's
interesting
lots of bone heaps is that like the only
rare one in the
skeleton deck
oh no headless horseman that's right
that is a pretty powerful one and i do
get a lot of bones so maybe i could
build more around that
okay
ship they always include one rare that's
awfully nice of them
whoa what is that tomb robber pay one
bone to create a skeleton in your hand
that's so useful
that's so and it's free to play
oh
the synergy
i don't know why i'm excited about this
stuff like it's it's so crazy that i'm
excited about this like card back
opening but i'm like oh yeah whoa
after attacking revenant parishes
a three bone for three damage yeah i'm
okay with that
oh yeah whoa frank and stein
frankenstein
i didn't know there would still be like
rare ones to find let me get another one
of these guys i don't even think i got
the zombie
and a skellington always useful all
right one more pack and then i'm gonna
go get a
different pack i'm gonna go get the uh
blood pack because i want to get more
field mice so that i can do more of the
mushroom combining because that's really
what i'm all about here
hello lashi how you doing good to see
you all right go away forever
all right uh
i mean squirrels might be nice the
auraboros
i forgot about you
give me you
yes please
yes please beastly pack let's get some
field mice
uh
nope that's not field nice
come on field mice
i'll go far more if i have to i don't
care i i don't care
i gotta level up my aura boris that's
all i it's fine with me
i'm oh i'll feel my stereo okay that's
one more
field mice there we go okay
dope
excellent
all right so that's all the packs i can
get
um let me go combine at the sporman if i
gotta go get more uh magic packs uh
because i don't have enough um of the
card picking ones then that's fine
okay here we go do the same oh yeah you
know you know i do
you know i do
thank you okay let's see about
oh
that's different
oh no wait no that was the thing that's
right that was one of them
so it's like one of each of these types
of cards has one thing that they can
combine
it's getting real bloody in here it's
getting like really bloody let's see if
i got any more field mice with
without me knowing nah i don't have it
okay but that's okay i think this is
more than enough to get what needs to be
done done
uh which is just beat this game there's
two cards they still haven't gone well
mystery cards
they don't exist
yeah but now i can make just
a sweet deck one two three one two three
uh
i mean no reason not to have all 10
right i say
let's see 10 of those
um these three
skelemajus well what if i don't actually
put any like magic stuff in my deck
because it doesn't seem tremendously
useful
to be perfectly honest i seem to be
getting along fine without it
uh you know what i mean i suppose i
could do some tactically good ones like
these revenants which could take out
some high-powered things yes okay what
about in here the auroboros i have to
have the auroboris in my hand i have to
it's too good the mantis is also very
good because it can attack more than one
thing i mean this is looking like a
pretty capable deck the only thing i
might do is get more skeletons because
they're free to play and
why not right i wonder if there's a way
if you play these together at the same
time
well no other time like the present i
can go test that on the dummy if it'll
do anything sorry this is just like me
experimenting but i'm having fun with
this huh so shut up it's fine i can have
fun
i can have fun if i want to can i still
fight you
oh hell yeah i can okay i'm just gonna
try to see what happens when this oval
goes and in the meantime i'm just gonna
be digging up
a lot of uh bones okay there's one half
of it
come on where's my grave man
maybe a few too many uh
maybe a few too many skeletons i guess i
have this guy who can just make
skeletons on the fly and he's free to
play
than having so many of these ah there we
go okay
you do not have enough bones well i
would if my
uh
if my sporeman was here there you are
oh right
okay and then i i guess what happens if
i
i'm gonna do a thing
because it's
it's when you
this thing dies it gets stronger right
there it is all right i think i've found
a way to do an endless loop of this
uh because if i put this here
then i'll just get endless cards for
that right
i think so yeah i think too many
skeletons
definitely too many skeletons
definitely too many skeletons there's
the other one only way late to the game
but it's fine oh yeah i forgot what i
was actually doing here i'm not trying
to farm stuff i'm trying to get the oval
pieces
so you're there and you're there
ah
it worked
whoa you received an ancient oblong
[Music]
i knew it oh wonder if i could get more
than one
nah i can't get more than one damn
that's fine that's fine where's my
ribbers or boy there you are okay so
i'm gonna put two skellingtons down
i'm gonna kill two skellingtons
i'm gonna kill you
i'm gonna put two skellingtons down
i'm gonna kill two skeletons i'm gonna
put you down i'm gonna kill you i'm
gonna put two skeletons down
i'm gonna kill two skellingtons i'm
gonna put that down i'm gonna kill two
skellingtons i'm gonna put
[Music]
put that down
i've officially broken this game and i
love it yeah 25 is more than good enough
but you there put you there let's go
ahead and beef you out oh wait you're
24. oh well
you know i can't just leave it at that
that's too low i can't leave it like
that
gotta do more okay now it's at 25.
all right you're there
and 25 and 25. thank you bam
love that i love this that this is here
there's something pleasant about farming
like any time i played like a final
fantasy game i actually enjoyed the
farming and grinding of it but i've done
enough farming and grinding uh let me
redo my deck a bit not so many skeletons
because the tomb ropper is so powerful
compared to it i want more
skeletons
but
not too many
i guess you know there really isn't a
problem with having too many skeletons
because
i can always just play more skeletons as
i get them
and i have the ancient oval which i
don't know what that means
i don't see it in my inventory what does
ancient opal mean yeah so there was
there must have been a secret in the the
factory with that thing going by i just
didn't know what it was there must be
something for it but i just am unsure
what uh necromancer could be good
because then i could get double bones
but they cost three but they do stuff so
why not i could have just get two i only
need two of those let's do that ghost
ship let's just do two of those because
why not
right why not and one headless horseman
30 out of 20. i like it
i like it let's fight
let's actually make progress i've been
stuck forever on this just imagine a
cloud floating above a volcano oh you
want a rematch i sure do
i sure do
okay i love this this is what i have
been talking about well i do need to
kill that thing eventually because it'll
kill that thing but also at the same
time he can take a few hits from that
but he costs one
so
yeah
i'll kill him in a moment
but i'll get this guy out
by killing that guy right away putting
him down he can take a few hits from
that thing if i give my mantis god i can
kill it well no i couldn't kill it but i
have more so they can dig up more bones
yeah let's do that
because he can get the bone economy
going right away
and then skellington let's go ahead and
kill that thing so it can stop hurting
my sporemen i suppose i could put this
down and just
pop them up right away so we can at
least kill this thing it'll put down a
moxie which means that thing doesn't go
away
i probably should have waited on that
i gotta be careful i'm gonna die so when
he gets there he's not gonna attack that
one
okay and then
that's fine there
okay that's damage bones bones bones
good bones bones bones
all right
so those guys are now done and dusted i
need to do some damage to him that's
what i'm gonna do do that
and get some skeletons in my hand
because i have more necromancers
easy
kill that one
put a skeleton in his place bam
wham
pile of bones
okay
ah the moxie's got power
well i gotta kill things before it gets
out of hand i could sweep them all out
with this that'd be easy enough
and then it could stop hitting my
my boneman
wham wham wham
makes it pretty easy
bone bone bone bone
now we're in business
now my friends we are in business
bone bone bone bone
i can't believe these things lived i'm
i'm kind of shocked actually that worked
out really nicely uh
this will toss it back in my favor
that's gonna power that so it'll kill
that but that's okay they've served
their purpose they got me lots of bones
which i love them for
um but now
my friend you have to die
and you will eventually die from the
assault of these well you're gonna die
from that so it doesn't really matter
and then you die
sorry
oh no
then mantis god is back
i've still got 18 cards left to pull
from uh so
i'm just going to wait for my aerobrus
and then i'm going to punish you for
existing this is what you get for being
a head on a pike in a molten landscape
this feels mean but you know i'm a mean
guy so whatever where's my rubberis i'm
waiting for the
roost
oh well that helps you know
[Music]
a river
a riverous did i already pull him no
there he is okay cool thank you thank
you pop you there no not you where's
another bone heap
this bone build is just delightful i
love the bone build
very
[Music]
bone builders
i love the
bone bill's so good
it's so good
it's got like endless things that you
could do
perhaps i will not be central to his
strategy i care not he can use me as a
chump blocker i have mastered
disappointment take this pack
i'll tell him that you want to you know
it's pretty cool i guess master orlu
when master orlew deals damage directly
draw a card for each damage dealt
does he ever get buffed because that's
really kind of the
the crux of that anyway go
all right okay okay bye
i'm gonna go i guess
ah interesting
no reason the top sigil is found by the
greedy
the bottom sigil is found by the heart
of hearing or by those who hear too
easily
the middle sigil is found by the pale
[Music]
oh
okay
right the greedy so that would be the
chest
top sigil
chest is empty for a single card hey a
rabbit
i'll take that
you reach back in for more and notice
the sigil where the card used to be okay
so
wing is the top sigil
found by the pale
by the pale
let's try wing skull and then i'll just
cycle through
pretend i found the other ones
oh there we go got it but oh
my god at last stimulation my test has
been sensory deprivation you see to
unlock the full potential of my mind you
see it's unlocked now hear me
magnificent i'm ready have we have to
battle okay oh wow uh
okay all right then
oh yeah gem fiend you are looking spicy
my friend all right hovermage will
strike an opponent directly
well
that's cool
that's cool man
that's real cool man
all right cool
wham wham wham
and more bones for me please
i don't think so
wham wham wham
oh yes please yes please oh wow i can't
take care of that thing hmm well fine
it's not even part of my strategy so
what does it matter
ow my thing
i guess your thing is also going to die
ow
skeleton time um
let's hold off a little longer i want to
get some excess damage you know my pride
and all
can i attack that flying thing i think
so yeah i definitely can
all right well uh looks like it might be
game over for you buddy
well might be super game over for you
buddy there he is
[Music]
okay there we go i've i'm taking way too
long on these fights because i'm i've
now have control over him so that's been
lovely for me but it's taking too long i
gotta get to this boss
i said that i was gonna finish this and
i did not
that was incredibly stimulating we
aren't done here right i wish to see the
light again to sing to dance you
wouldn't leave would you oh you know
maybe i might oh master garage whoa
that's a lot of health
alright goodbye i'm gonna leave now if i
open the door you'll stop by on the way
back and let me out right
yeah actually i feel like i would i feel
like i should so i think i will
oh
this is lovely hey how you doing buddy
the note reads dearest grimora i believe
po3's plot may go far past the extent of
a common power grab indeed this great
transcendence will have catastrophic and
unpredictable results the note is
incomplete and offensive and abruptly i
urge you to consider
and then i guess the worst came to pass
what is all this
leaky pipe a fountain of some kind
water
oh hi
oh great kraken great kraken submerges
itself during its opponent's turn while
submerged opposing creatures attack its
owner directly
thanks
i think thank you
all right anyway hi lesh uh no you're
not letchy grimora you're here last time
into my people's fare no matter there
are far more concerning issues at hand
do you understand that canvas that you
have been woven into
nay you are the brush and the artist
moves you with terrifying mastery oh god
my eye aches with premonition and i see
that your ambition is to take my title
how sad it will never happen you see
even if you defeat me but i'm bound by
certain rules
first we must battle okay
i didn't know that i
that's a vine hold the brush of the
scribe of magics
my pupils would die to be painted by it
and live forever as a card but that is
not the full extent of its powers
this one needs some bleach hey
oh
now for a bit of color
hey oh
come on
my god oh hi dude
oh look at you
look at you wow that's a lot of health
okay well i'm just gonna get a new hand
i think
oh you're repainting everything
oh you're an a-hole
no
my abilities
my synergy
well that's unfortunate for me all right
cool then all right cool you all are now
very useless thank you for participating
in my exercise of futility uh
of this
hi buddy how you doing he did want to
dance so
proud of him
very proud
i guess i'll be here for when that guy
attacks sure
oh god you have power now
that's unfair
thanks thank you all good thank you very
much
at least they don't die immediately now
[Music]
oh man i didn't know that this was how
this is gonna go oh a rabbit well that's
different okay cool
skeleton pulls out a rabbit
all right
max power gains one power
[Music]
well despite this turn of events i seem
to still be winning
[Music]
so uh there's that i guess
i don't have anything that could do a
lot more damage besides the aeroborus
hmm i must be slowing down with age i
may need to set my brush upon my own
cards once again
thanks thank you
thank you
anyway
ow
uh-huh
well that was fun to have for for a
while
but whatever
guess i'll get a rabbit
great
very well
oh i won
well that was easy
bone deck all the way very well we have
battled and now i may speak you see
my eye it aches because it remembers it
was excised
by none other than oh that's the eye in
the box from a previous episode that i
took and put in my own eye ball socket
by none other than les she the scribe of
the beasts and a beast he was arrogant
single-minded obsessed with gaining
power but he's far from the worst scribe
to become hegemon you see the ejection
of my eyeball is far from the worst
thing that can happen around here you
must be especially
what the hell
what happened
oh
okay i don't know if oh okay more
thank you okay
um
i guess we're done here
there's something weird on this island
with all the glitches that are occurring
there's something going on and i don't
know what it is maybe i can get behind
here nah like i don't know
i know there was something in that
factory with that cube i know that
but i just don't know what it was
what was it
also what did i do did i win
am i done
[Music]
okay
it is time challenger choose the scribe
that you will replace oh now
right now
right right right now
um
i mean they're all pretty awful
uh i can't oh my god
uh i wasn't prepared to make a decision
i thought the decision was made for me
and i'm crippled with indecision now
that i have to make a decision alright
well let's think about this
last year was clearly a douche in terms
of what he did in the first part of the
game but these guys are also kind of
dicks except for the bone lady po3 is an
indifferent uncaring calculating machine
gramora is like a torturous bastard at
least lest he lived in harmony with the
animals i think of all these people the
most sinful is this guy right here so it
kind of was chosen for me but i kind of
agree with it and i'm already wearing
like a wizard's outfit so whatever
replace magnificus and become the scribe
of the magics
but i did like the bones oh is it is it
gonna lock me into something because i
really like my bone deck i don't like
the magic dick very much
i like the bone deck but okay let me i'm
gonna make the decision based on what i
think story wise is relevant which i
think is this it's what i was picked for
me in the beginning and honestly i don't
like him
okay
i already know i've lost i've foreseen
it my eye aches once again why must my
pathetic slime mage always fail
but would i be so meticulous in my
preparedness if i myself had tasted
power alas
i may never know
show yourself fiendish machine
oh hi
alas ill-fate await us
all old fool i don't know you anything
now let's play
oh
you supposed to battle the scribe that
you picked but like a powered up version
for the finale this is going to be
different
okay
interesting
let me redo that draw okay this is a
little better
this is something you know
hmm well this is unfortunate
huh
i have 10 bajillion skeletons
i'm not getting any
whoa i'll just leave this here
i've got to give it to that dredger
not as useless as i thought
oh that's the thing
that's the thing i saw i don't know what
that do but uh let me try to smack it
take this
oh god
oh wow
that's the ticket what's the ticket
[Applause]
oh
so it turns out po3 was the most evil of
them all what
oh my god hello
[Music]
oh hi
hello
how are you
good to see you
you done gawking no not yet
we can start
good
uh whoa this is bootopia a once great
technological paradise
it's ruled over by four uh
uber bots that's right and you've got to
get out of there and beat them why
to perform the great transcendence of
course it doesn't matter what that means
you want it okay
okay
oh oh
wait can i step away from this table
botopia used to be safe for travelers
now rogue bots block all the major roads
oh
get up no we've got transcending to do
interesting
wait what is that over there
it was a flicker of something
what is that
[Music]
something over there
whoa
oh interesting new cards
okay
i'm gonna leave this here because i'm
all out time for this episode but we
have entered apparently the third phase
of this game which has taken another
turn and all of my beautiful cards are
now gone
i knew there was something with that
block i just couldn't have done anything
with it i guess but anyway thank you all
so much for watching this is getting so
fun
it's been fun but i love it it's super
cool
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video
[Music]
you